hi I'm William Jackson Harper from the
good place and dark waters she's some
thirsty tweaks Hey um any the good place
fans sometimes just think about
shirtless Chiti no I mean I'm a fan I
certainly don't think about it any more
than I have to
was a frightening day yeah yeah I was so
shocked about that reaction I was just
thinking like I was hoping that everyone
would just sort of like just pay
attention to the joke and not comment on
anything because I was afraid that if I
was like looking with you know I gotta
look in my head that people just feel
like oh there's something seriously
wrong with that really she put a shirt
back on William Jackson Harper trust me
with your thighs I know you can so you
might as well I did the legs need a lot
of work Kristen Bell told me one time
like that and you and in shorts it's
like with the guy riding a chicken
William Jackson Harper if you're out
there please let me eat that I mean no
no I using it nothing like seeing GD
shirtless in a good place to remind me
that I'm bisexual glad a few service
where on earth was William Jackson
Harper hiding those pecs god damn Chiti
under my shirt just under my shirt and
the whole bunch of sweater vests BRB
devoting an entire web domain to every
muscle and William Jackson the hunters
physique
thank thank you yeah my my my left PEC
in particular needs need to zone it
needs to be unpacked saw a guy on campus
who look like William Jackson Harper
whoo I would climb him like a tree great
I mean climb that dude I mean like
you're the other thing is you know like
I'm not I'm not real tall so it's not a
far climb you know we probably just kind
of shaking hands and giving like a
piggyback or something you actually
probably want to give me a piggyback
they do turns out the good place was
cheetahs abs all along thank you thank
you thank you for that I've been working
on we don't talk about William Jackson
Harper's arms enough tbh I I mean I I'm
fine much they're being talked about
this it's totally fine don't mind being
objectified but I don't want to I don't
want to be a douchebag either and you be
like hell yeah you're right
William Jackson Harper has such a
soothing sexy voice I just want to hear
him talk forever well that's that's nice
because I feel like I'm still going
through puberty like my voice cracks all
the time we have to do a lot of like ADR
because my voice cracks so much every
day that passes that I am not being held
in William Jackson Harper's tender
loving surprisingly ripped arms is a
tragedy I think thanks oh god like I'm
starting to have starting to sweat I
would let William Jackson Harper blank
blank blank blank blank blank blank
blank blank me I don't even know what
like how many blank it's a lot of blanks
that is the beds like a hell of a verb
like whatever we're gonna be doing
together I have no idea what it is I
mean cuz all the things that I can think
about are like three or four letters
long and this is the fact that this is 8
some some sort of long word and and the
zeitgeist now that I don't know about
William Jackson Harper shirtless is how
I know I'm not in the bad place well
that's this this sweet I'm totally
afraid of being shirtless like pretty
much all the time like girls said
everyone between those things it it
makes me feel great and objectified
which is fine for me I enjoy that it's a
little uncomfortable in a good way
some sweaty sweaty
[Music]
you
[Music]